okay so puppeteer just kidding
I'm Carmen you can follow me on Twitter
you can check out my blog
Margy map is a map that I work on it
shows a visualization of income to
Internet to libraries which provide
Internet you should check it out it's
really sweet I've done some talks about
it so I love it and I'd love to talk to
you about it so hit me up you might be
wondering what is puppeteer has anybody
in here used puppeteer familiar with it
okay alright alright you'll have to keep
me honest is anybody in here done any
web scraping with a thing besides
puppeteer maybe not even in JavaScript
seeing a couple more hands so puppeteer
can be used for a lot of things in this
particular talk we're gonna talk about
web scraping so puppeteer is a node API
for headless Chrome headless Chrome is a
program that Chrome has put out to be
able to use their browser without a GUI
and to be able to automate things
puppeteer has an API to control headless
Chrome and it also uses the dev tools
protocol which is pretty cool you should
check it out
so I already mentioned a couple things
that puppeteer can be useful for but you
can use it to generate screenshots in
PDFs of webpages you can also pass in
HTML which is really handy I'm going to
show you guys an example of that later
on you can automate form submission for
UI testing this is a really big thing
that people like to use puppeteer for is
combining it with other testing Suites
to help make their testing better you
can capture a trace to help diagnose
performance issues and you can do web
scraping the first and last one are what
we're gonna do in this talk today really
quick note about asynchronous javascript
in puppeteer so typically when we're
using asynchronous JavaScript or using
promises right and we're using the dot
then syntax puppeteer doesn't do that
really you can but typically puppeteer
uses a sink and a weight so if you're
not familiar with that you will be by
the end of this talk you can use the dot
then syntax if you want to I don't know
if I could recommend it and you'll see
here a couple examples where it's like
you would have like what do they used to
say callback what I don't want to say it
cuz we're on the stream but you guys
know what I'm talking about so you would
have that with promises it would be like
way over because of all the nesting so I
would definitely use async in a weight
it makes for cleaner code so let's
control some stuff so a little bit about
puppeteer Before we jump into some code
you're gonna see this a lot this browser
it's a class when you launch puppeteer
you get an instance of a browser back if
you wanted to you could it has a whole
bunch of different options in the launch
function but if you set headless to
false it'll actually pop up a window for
you to see what all is going on which if
you're doing like form inputs or like
other Dom manipulation that can be kind
of cool to watch you'll just want to
make sure that you put like a set
timeout in there because it's really
really fast and so literally like if you
blink you can miss it so just keep that
in mind the other thing you're gonna see
a lot of is this concept of a page this
is another class it provides methods
where you can interact with a tab or
extension a browser can contain multiple
pages you might also see this called a
tab but essentially it's just your your
Dom so if we wanted to navigate to a web
page this is probably the very most
simple example you'll see we have to
require a puppeteer and then we've got
that async function and I was telling
you about
within that you've got a browser that's
puppet to your adult launch like I said
it takes in a bunch of options but you
don't really have to pass
and you can do you know most things that
you're gonna see in this presentation
you're gonna instantiate a page so
that's browser dot new page you can set
your viewport that's important for if
you're like taking screenshots or if you
want to see your page so you can define
the width and height and then the last
excuse me the second to last line that
page go to that's just you're passing in
a URL and you're saying hey go to this
page and then at the end of it you want
to close because if you don't close the
browser then you could get a memory leak
and it'd be done
make it sense so far all right super so
if you wanted to take a screenshot
that's gonna look incredibly similar to
what we were just doing so you'll notice
that there's really only one line of
difference and I even marked it with a
comment or it says this is the important
part
so you launch puppet to your again you
go to the new page well you instantiate
the new page excuse me
you can set your viewport you go to it
once you're there you can simply call
page dot screenshot and pass in the
options being paths that's really really
important if you don't want it to end up
in the same directory that you're
currently running your program from if
you want it in like a screenshots
directory you have to specify that as
part of the path and then full page I
always set to true but you can tell it
like only take this section of the page
if you want to get really fancy and then
we close it that's about it
pretty simple everybody good so far all
right great you can get a page source so
that's like does anybody ever use this
anymore were you like or you guys just
all just like me where it's like you try
to inspect but you hit page source
instead and you're like I don't want
this well just in case you do actually
want that this is how you would do it
just a quick note I have ellipses just
to kind of show for the next several
examples that we're still in an async
function you can't run this stuff
outside of an async function but it was
meaning really on
so that's what those mean so we're
instantiating the browser instantiating
the page you notice on the go-to
function this time there's a second
parameter an object what network idle to
means is where we go to the page and
then we wait until there's no more
network requests and what network idle -
specifically means is that there haven't
been two network requests in the last
500 milliseconds that's really important
because like when you're loading in CSS
when you're loading in JavaScript when
you're loading and everything those are
all happening over network and so you
want to wait until that's actually all
been completed before you grab all the
content or you know execute whatever
code you're wanting to execute and then
I marked it again where it says this is
the important part what we're gonna do
is we're just going to call page content
and that will give you the entire source
code of the page all of the markup all
of the value everything the whole thing
and then you know whatever you'd want to
do with that maybe you want to write it
to a file yourself or you know whatever
you want to do you would do that next
and then again at the end we always want
to close our browser so we don't get
memory leaks so a little bit more about
puppeteer and some examples well before
we dive into those I want to talk to you
about some extra functions so it has
this really handy wait for selector
function and so that accepts a selector
and you can get really super specific
with it so you could do like paragraph
dot class child and you can go really
really far out it's very handy and so
what that does is that ways for that
specific selector to appear in the page
this is really important for client-side
rendered apps where you know maybe stuff
is there when it loads in and maybe it's
not so if there's something specific
that you're waiting for you can use wait
for selector and it'll pause until that
selector is actually in the page I have
an example showing why that's important
page dot evaluate is another really
common one that I've run across so it
accepts a function parameter
and it's not executing that function in
your puppeteer file it's actually
executing that in the DOM and so if you
are wanting if you're wanting to get
element by ID or you know any other Dom
manipulation you would pass it in
through a page dot evaluate yes that
will return whatever that so if you did
like get element by ID that will return
the actual element back into your puppet
to your file does that make sense
super and then we already talked about
network idle too but again it's just
indicating that navigation is complete
there aren't any more network requests
and there haven't been for you know five
hundred milliseconds so if you wanted to
get a list of github repos this is how
you might do it we're going to my github
page and notice at the top we've figured
out what selector we want that very
first repo links and we are using wait
for selector because it's not
necessarily going to be there when you
first hit the page so you want to make
sure that the selector that you want
actually exists on your page or else
you'll get puppeteers errors are kind of
not easy to read it usually looks like a
promise rejection and you're just like
this is not specific what's going on so
it's helpful if you wait for selectors
and you know anything that you are
planning on accessing while you're in
the page just make sure that it's
actually there before you try to access
it so then this right here is page dot
evaluate so we're passing in a function
where we use a query selector we pass in
repo links which is the very specific
thing that I'm looking for that's gonna
return a it's that no collection I
forget exactly what it's called but it
doesn't return an array so we convert
that to an array and we map over it and
then we just return the link to the
specific or
and so if you were to run if you were to
swap this out for say your github page
which you would get is your top 30
repository links in an array and you
could write that to a file or whatever
else you were wanting to do I want to
make a really quick note about screen
scraping between you and Nate I wouldn't
do it this way github has a really
really sweet API that you could use and
it just way way easier
I would really only do screen scraping
in the event that there's not a really
great API but lucky for you I have an
example of that too
yes
network idle to you yes so it just waits
to make sure that there haven't been any
network connections in the last 500
milliseconds it's really important to
make sure that all of your files have
been loaded in your JavaScript in your
CSS and all that stuff all right very
good so even more about puppeteer I know
you guys are loving it so what we're
gonna see in our next example is some
actual Dom interaction so I wanted to
list off a couple of functions so that
you know what they are before we see
them in the example this first one focus
this probably looks a lot like methods
that you would use in a javascript file
and they're really similarly named
that's intentional this will accept a
selector and it'll put focus on it so if
you give it like an input box it'll put
focus on the input box page keyboard
type it will actually simulate key
presses so if you have an event listener
on a specific key press this is a really
great way to make sure that that's
actually being triggered and it'll also
input text into like a text box or a
text area or anything like that click is
probably pretty self-explanatory but
again it accepts a selector and it
simulates a click on it so if you have a
if you have navigation on a click or if
you have an event listener or anything
like that that's a great way to make
sure that that's working as expected
and then wait for wait for is really
really similar to wait for selector
which we saw before except that this one
will accept a function and so it's
really really handy for actually having
an example of this coming up if you want
to make sure that value is there you can
pass a function into wait for and it
will pause essentially your program
until the value is there I don't want to
give too much away but I have an example
that so this is like my favorite one
that I did because I feel really
rebellious does anybody in here have
students you don't have tell me I do so
between you and me if you have great
links you can use this too
I'm sorry
so the problem that I was having was it
like my specific site doesn't store
historical data and you know I'm a busy
person I can't remember to go in and
check it every single day and so I was
like haha you can't trick me I will
write a screen scraping application
because you know naturally they're not
going to provide an API so this one is
quite a few more steps but the first
step is those functions I was showing
you before where we're actually doing
Dom interaction so initially we've seen
this a whole bunch of times we're gonna
go to the specific URL where our site is
again if you have Great Lakes this will
work for you
run it on a Raspberry Pi you can be a
rebel like me so we're gonna focus on
that specific ID in this case that ID is
an input box so we focus on it and then
we put in a user name
we're gonna click it's a next button
essentially and so for some reason
they've broken it out into multiple
pages so that's why this is so big once
we click Next we've got another selector
we another input box we focus on it we
put in the next piece of data we click
Next and then that third section these
all look really similar
it's another page with another input box
you put in the data you click Next so
that part's kind of boring this is where
though wait for comes in real handy so
after I've logged in at the end of that
last example like we put in data and we
click Next and we do that a bunch of
times then you actually you know you're
logged in and you get into the page you
want to be in so fortunately they were
really nice yes yes there's actually a
wait for navigation function you can use
yes the question was does this follow
redirects and yes it does there's a wait
for navigation function you can use
where you just it's like page dot wait
for navigation and it'll wait for the
redirect to be complete and then
continue that wasn't something I used in
here because I used wait for selector
instead which kind of achieved the same
thing so my particular program tracks
the current balance the unpaid interest
and the unpaid and the unpaid principal
and unpaid interest so it ended up in
this really funny thing that you get
with client-side apps where just because
the selector is there does not mean that
the value from their API call is in the
selector right so you load in your
template and then after that you get
your API bat you get your API return
back and then you load in everything
right it's just familiar okay so I was
running into this problem where it was
like it was working but my I wasn't
getting my expected output I was getting
a bunch of undefined and that was
because of I don't happen to know what
client-side rendering they're using like
if it's angular or reactor what it is
but it was it was giving me this problem
and so that's where I passed that
function in to wait for and so I'll show
you what that looks like
essentially all it's doing is it's
targeting the value of the input and
it's saying you know if it's not empty
string then you can continue and so
it'll pause at each wait for it'll say
is this empty string and if it's not
it'll go to the next and it'll go to the
next and it'll just continue on like
that
so everybody follow great so this is
where we actually get to scrape the data
yay
it's really sad data I'm sorry to tell
you because it's student loans right so
we're gonna use page evaluate and we're
just gonna do some Dom it's not
manipulation but you know some
interaction we're gonna use get element
by ID and target to enter HTML that gets
returned back to puppeteer because
remember when you execute something in
page dot evaluate it's actually
executing in the Dom it's not executing
in puppeteer and so you always always
always want to return it back so it can
get back to the variable everybody
follow and then at the end of that you
know I've got the data that I want I can
use node to write it to a file or do
whatever I want with it once that's
completed I can close my browser
everybody good so we're going to also
generate a PDF with puppeteer it's
really really similar you know we're
gonna start out by launching the browser
we're gonna instantiate a new page we're
gonna tell it to go to a specific URL
and then we're gonna call page dot PDF
if you've ever tried to generate a PDF
on your own I have and it's terrible is
not a fun thing to try too so I was
super stoked when I found that puppeteer
had this you know relatively simple
method that I could just call and I
actually I'm using it in a project so it
takes in PDF takes in a whole bunch of
options if you leave out the options
it'll probably it'll probably work it's
going to default to like
eight-and-a-half by eleven like normal
page size PDF if you want something you
know more specified that's when your
options are going to come in
real handy but the one that you
absolutely want to have is path and that
is where you give it the name of your
PDF and also again I'd mentioned with
screenshots if you want it to go to a
different directory than where you're
running the file you want to specify
that in your file path as well everybody
good with that
so I had also mentioned that you can
actually pass markup in to puppeteer
which is what I'm doing in a project I
have a project where someone comes in
and they fill out a form and based on
their form inputs I generate a PDF for
them and this is essentially how I'm
doing it you know obviously like I'm not
hard coding my HTML but I end up with
the HTML from what they've put into the
form and then instead of page go to we
use page set content and so you don't
have to have a live website to be able
to use this you can just have markup and
pass it in and it'll treat it like it's
a live website so you do page set
content that you know renders it for you
in their in their DOM and then you just
call a wait page PDF the exact same way
and then you close the browser I can't
stress that enough you really want to
close your browser and that's not all do
you guys want to see some demos yes okay
sweet
here's the funny thing about showing
demos of automated stuff is it's like
I'm gonna type it in and it's gonna be
like oh that's really cool cuz it's like
oh it's done yes yes can I make it
larger is that better okay so if we were
gonna generate a PDF with markup we
would just you know run that generate
PDF with markup so this is the one where
we're passing in the HTML there is no I
mean maybe there is but I didn't make a
web page that says hello okay CJ yes
it's not butter okay sweet so I'm gonna
run this and yay okay so I'm gonna show
you what it actually did pop this open
and I think this was the most recent one
it made a PDF for us yay
so um it it's not like super exciting
like writing a game or something where
you like have something like really
really neat to show for it at the end
but I can tell you for me it was super
helpful to be able to use in my project
where I didn't have to figure out how to
convert a byte array into a PDF and like
all of those shenanigans like being able
to just have some markup and throw it
into puppeteer and come back with the
PDF was just it saved me I don't know
weeks of time for sure and then also the
the student loans when like like I said
it was kind of cool because I was like
haha you can't trick me student loan
place so if we run that I'm only gonna
show you guys this one really quick cuz
I don't want you guys to be sad for me
and how much money I owe
but anyway so you can see like every day
it's running and it's tracking that for
me so that I don't have to you know
login every single day because I'm not
going to remember to do it like we're
busy people
No so showed you some demos are there
any puppet to your questions yes can
puppeteer do multi-page yes it can
so what you would do is you would just
have you could store it in like an
object or something but remember when we
did launch puppeteer and we instantiated
a browser a browser can have multiple
pages oh yes yes it can I have an
example of that I'm glad you asked so if
we did generate PDF so what this does is
it takes a screenshot of like my blog
and it actually looks pretty good I feel
like not on my blog like the PDF the
blog looks good too
I'm like putting my so yeah it does this
is what it ends up looking like is it's
like really long because I talk a lot
but yeah it will do multi-page for you
and you can you can go a lot further
with the formatting than what I showed
in the example like you can you can get
like really really specific with how you
want it formatted in the examples I kept
it pretty basic does that answer your
question yes if I found any shortcomings
to its ability to screen scrape I
thought it was very fully featured and
really powerful the biggest complaint I
had about screen scraping which is how
really tedious it is I mean I can't
stress enough like if there's an
available API that you can use instead
like genuinely I would do that but if
you need to generate PDFs I thought that
was really great you know
historical screenshots that's really
great being able to execute a function
within Dom itself was just like it was
incredibly helpful I wouldn't have been
able to achieve this stuff without it so
overall I would say no I think it's a
really really great program yes
the question was is there a way to
automate the run every day so I
mentioned in the tracking the student
loan data that it runs every day within
puppeteer I don't know of a way to
automate it every day I wrote and I
wrote another program and it's running
on a Raspberry Pi so basically it just
calls out to this the question was are
there any real like big real world
projects um I know well people use it
for a lot of automated testing so they
prepare it what their testing suite and
they run it through puppeteer I'm
working on a more personal project with
it I don't know of any like big
companies that are using it I'm sure
they're out there I just didn't think to
look that up more questions yes
lighthouse oh okay okay oh nice
so lighthouse uses it so yeah awesome
that's really cool yes that's a can the
PDF saved to a stream I don't know I
haven't tried to do that I just saved it
to a file
good alright I was just kidding that's
not all vans mentioned Thunder Plains
I'm gonna be there I'm gonna be talking
about service workers if you want to
save some coin you can use okay CJ s18
and it's awesome and you should go
seriously I love Thunder plains and
that's it